congratulations thank you you've been
friends with Brooke for years now who
approached him first to tell Brooke's
story in Brook's words I approached
Brooke and I said your life is
incredibly complex and interesting and
should be a documentary the entirety
of my life it was she's a pretty face
over and over and over and over and over
again and that always just
seared me I think there's an even bigger
umbrella which is how our culture has
sexualized girls starting with you
Brooke
yeah so I think that there are many
lessons in it as well as a story of a
woman who's persevered and what was so
great from the beginning is that she
understood that in goes with Ali saying
that she's fearless she had to give up
control for this to get done and she was
willing to do that and it created it
helped create just an amazing film that
really says something big about the
country today and the country when she
was growing up I was struggling to find
my own voice I wasn't told it was
important to have agency I mean she
talks about some deeply personal
traumatic moments including her sexual
assault so as executive producers as her
friends how do you approach difficult
topics like that with such care well
first of all it's her story so it's just
if she wanted to tell it that's great
we'll support her and second of all we
only helped sort of scaffold how the
message would come out so that you know
she was somewhat protected and but she
was very clear about you know what she
wanted to say about it and how she felt
her message would Empower other women
and we completely supported him
incredible how do you feel like her
experiences early on have impacted who
she is today I think it's made her
incredibly resilient
um I think that it gave her the grit and
determination to keep moving forward in
a positive way I mean I say in the film
and I joke to her many times you should
either be in rehab or dead and you know
as much as is that kind of a funny
comment it's true and so and that's
because of who she is inside that she
was able to now have this amazing family
and literally be a mom friend they had
so many different sides here what you
see in this movie you see your humor you
see her grit you see her work ethic you
see her empathy and you see someone who
has run a gauntlet and come out I mean
that's what's so inspiring about it I
heard someone else that's very inspiring
your friend Michael J fox he's coming
out with a new documentary I can't wait
to see it now we're best friends
the friend group here is just on fire
right now it's really exciting
incredible and there's a lot of Buzz
going on at gma3 DeMarco and Geo are
rumored to be candidates for gma3
hosting duties
I'm too tired and old thank you they're
doing great
foreign